you have to look back at the one one
movie that you're most proud of oh I
know that's hard I I don't know proud I
don't know what proud means less than
zero that was a terrible experience I
did not enjoy that at all um well I was
in a bad place in my life everyone was a
script was a mess that I didn't think
that was a successful movie
um and then we had to reshoot so much of
it because it was right in the middle of
Nancy Reagan just say no era suddenly
and you know we had scenes with flushing
cocaine down the toilet because the
studio Executives realized oh this movie
is being made about our kids no we can't
have the you know and there's not a word
of the book in the movie and stuff so
you know that movie particularly didn't
you know I thought Bobby Johnny was
great but he was also you know a little
too close to home for him in that moment
in time so what he wasn't that easy
because he was going through it well he
was lovely but he was just going through
whatever he's going through he's always
been a very sweet guy yeah